well if any team was not going to be
concerned about the fact that devonta
smith only weighs 166 pounds it's the
philadelphia eagles they know a thing or
two about having a short and skinny
receiver they had one in desean jackson
last time i checked he was pretty damn
good now they add a game breaker with
that move in front of the giants the
trade up with the cowboys yeah the
cowboys in the division the cowboys go
to 12. the eagles go to 10 they give up
a third round pick to do it and they cut
the line in front of the giants because
it was believed the giants wanted
devonta smith at number 11. the eagles
get devonta smith and now the cowboys
sit back and wait and see what happens
at 12
with a potential goal for signing or
drafting is the case may be an offensive
tackle but back to the eagles this is a
weapon they needed they have jaylen
rieger he was a disappointment last year
they have not had a lot of great
receiver help in recent years al shawn
jeffrey finally gone desean jackson also
gone they needed someone and now jalen
hurts second year quarterback another
weapon to help him reach his ceiling
whatever it may be because devontae
smith will be very dynamic both in the
offense and in the return game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports